There's nothing happening, man. There's nothing happening up
there. It's all empty. There's so much space up in this bald
dome right now. Okay. There's just infinite space up there. It's
actually a pocket dimension. Okay. You go you go in there. It
is the entirety of Buckingham Palace. Okay. All the space in
the
Okay. Yeah, that's a good title. That's a good title. All right.
We'll do that one first. Why not? Why not do that one first?
Very, very gross. Very weird stuff from our buddy Hutch. Okay.
All right. So, where do we start with this?
We can start with it. Actually, I threw the queen tweet in here
because that was what made me aware of this. I didn't even know
this happened. And then I saw Queen tweet this today.
So,
um Oh, actually, this comes in late. No, no, no. Never mind.
Never mind. Go to the Hutch tweet first. So, the Hutch tweet.
This is the Hutch tweet. Okay, now Hutch just throws this up
in I think it's in response to Taylor Ren's talking about Ethan
Klein in the past couple days, right? Taylor Ren's been going
off on Ethan Klein. Okay, Jacob, somebody can unban you. I just
listen, I have to keep it a policy or whatever. Okay. What is
incredible about her corner of the internet is that they are
a thousand% convinced that they're the good guys fighting evildoers
for a righteous cause. In their minds, there is nothing out of
bounds when they attack their enemies because their enemies are
ontologically evil.
Okay. I man
I mean maybe it seems that way with like a lot of people on the
left that that can't be the way it can be. Is that what Taylor
Loren is doing?
I don't I don't think that's what Taylor Loren is doing.
Whoever made the hockey orb avatar nailed it. Pretty cool. Yeah,
it is awesome. It is awesome.
So all he posts here is this cropped screenshot of a Taylor Loren
tweet. Okay. where Taylor Luren says, "I hope no one ever calls
CPS and Ethan Klein again. I can't emphasize enough how no one
should call CPS and report Ethan Klein for negligence and try
to get his children taken away. Under no circumstances should
you file a CPS case, report against Ethan Klein." Okay, which
on its own is weird. It's obviously looks like a tongue-in-cheek
way of saying, "Oh, you should actually do that. You should actually
do that."
Right? Now, on its own, that looks pretty bad. That looks like
she's telling people to go call CPS on Ethan Klein. Right.
That's what that looks like to me.
But it turns out that there's a bunch of context cropped out
of this. All right.
And Taylor Ren SP responds. She I believe she replies or she
quote tweets. I think she replies. Okay. She replies and says,
"Hey, that's like out of context entirely." And Hutch hides it.
I believe now that's what I read, but I didn't actually go check
for the hidden tweets. Hold on. Let's see. View hidden replies.
So, it's not here in hidden replies. I thought somebody somebody
said it was hidden, so I figured I' I'd check. Okay, maybe not.
But Taylor does have a quote tweet here. Hold on. Let me pull
the Taylor quote tweet so she can explain. All right. Now, Taylor
Soy, so we'll have to we'll have to translate a little bit. She
quote tweets him and says, "You intentionally cropped the post
I'm quote tweeting of Ethan Klein saying these exact words about
but about me." Okay, so this is subjective.
She's being a little soy here, okay, with the about me.
it's it's
kind of bad, you know, and I can totally understand. Like I think
it's exactly
commensurate the way she responds. Of course, no one would get
outraged if you included that key context. So you have to deceptively
crop my post to remove the context.
Okay. Uh oh, he knows he's just intentionally misleading people
about the context of my post in order to whip up more hate and
harassment towards me. Okay. So,
here's what she's complaining about, right? Ethan Klein continues
to play the victim while he incites violence against me and other
women. He knows how involved my soccer was in his community and
he has encouraged my stalker who's threatened me physically.
Now, Ethan is once again encouraging people to physically attack
me. So, I don't know what Ethan said about this that led to this.
Okay, we can look into that, too.
Picture fully animated again. It is right now, but this is what
he says, right? Do not cough near Loren if you see her. I cannot
emphasize this enough. Under no circumstances should you ever
cough near Taylor Loren. If you see her in a theater, leave.
If you spot her on the subway, pull the emergency cord. Do not
risk it. You may not know it, but just by reading this, you are
currently stalking her, which is a crime. You will go to jail
and I cannot afford to lose any more viewers. So, stop thinking
about her ever or stop thinking about her right now. Okay, so
it's this whole thing. This whole thing. And it's like, okay,
I didn't know this, but apparently Taylor Lorenz is imunompromised.
I'm sure if you hate her, you'd say this is her, you know, making
that up. But she seems to, you know, wear a mask when she goes
out places. She seems to be pretty, you know, big on making sure
she stays healthy. But she believes she's immuno compromised.
I have no reason to doubt that right now. Like it's super inconvenient
to live her life the way she does. That's not the case, right?
And and she responds with the CPS thing, which I think is one
to one. Uh, part one of two, the joke. Can someone just cough
on Taylor Lens already and put us all out of her misery? Oh,
so the joke is literally hinting at the fact that she's imunocmpromised.
Okay, so he understands, right?
He understands exactly what's going on and makes that joke. And
so she responds with the thing that pissed him off, right?
I I feel like it's one to one. I don't feel like it's crazy.
I don't feel like it's weird. Now, I will note Hutch has left
this up cropped entirely to just make it look like out of nothing,
she said call CPS and Ethan Klein, right?
Although, hold on. I should pull up this other thing.
Bro, did Aiden like predict this drama? No, it was the night
before. Okay. No, no, no. Okay. Yeah, Aiden just threw this out
out of nowhere. I saw this Aiden tweet. I don't know if you guys
saw the Aiden tweet. Okay. He did the one to one. He did the
one to one a couple nights ago. Okay. Jesus.
So,
let's see. There's a couple people here who do say it. Fact that
you had to hide the post she was replying to shows Oh, he apparently
hid the post this person's replying to. I don't think he did.
Or at least it's unhidden if it was hidden. Okay. I don't see
any. Oh, wait. Hold on. Yeah, I don't see
I don't see it. So, if it was hidden,
I don't see it. Can I see this? No.
Okay. I don't know what that reply was about, but that's fine.
Why'd you crop the context where Ethan is implicitly directing
his fans to harass Taylor Loren in public?
Oh, nobody responds to that. I'm looking for the big one.
Did I not save this? Taylor Loren's had it in one of her things.
There's like a big post here that's explaining the whole thing,
right? Not this one. It's a big one with a bunch of likes. The
is this? Well, I don't see it now. But I didn't I also didn't
see anything hidden, so that's fine. Oh, sure. Yeah, maybe Wendy.
Maybe. We'll see. Okay. So So going from there. Okay. We have
we have Hutch like obviously clipping this out of context. There
are a couple people who let him who let him know like very politely,
hey, this is wrong. This is like 100% wrong, okay? And he just
leaves it up. And I was like, oh, there's no way he can't just
like you got to either add the context or you got to acknowledge
this. Well, he covered it on stream. And at least from what I
saw on stream, it looked like he was going to totally deny
that anything was out of context there. So, let's see. >> My
um live and learn buddies are texting me about a Taylor Loren's
post. By the way,
I do think this is just like totally disingenuous. I should say
obviously it's completely disingenuous to do this, right? To
like crop somebody's tweet so it's totally without context, makes
them look like a one-sided bad guy. You're just trying to paint
a narrative. You are a propagandist at that point. Like Hutch
is operating as a propagandist here and unapologetically because
he could easily add the context. He could reply, he could delete
this tweet, he could do anything and instead he's just left it
here. Um, we'll see. Maybe at some point at the near the end
of his stream, he decided to bring it up and say, "Oh, actually,
I I was wrong." Nope.
Nope.
Nope. I don't see it.
He's doing the thing his tweet is about. Many such cases. Okay.
Many such >> cases. Underscore. Thank you for the five
gifted. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate
it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
I mean, nobody
plays a perpetual victim quite like she does, man. It's It is
remarkable.
>> It's him talking about Taylor Loren's now. I would argue
that Ethan Klein is right up there. Ethan Klein is almost as
capable a perpetual victim as Taylor Loren. Maybe he's he's I
mean, at this point, I'm starting to get them, you know, they're
neck and neck and Taylor Loren to me is like the height of, you
know, self victimization on the internet. But Ethan Klein's getting
there. He really is. >> I posted about this last night.
Um, so she and and quite frankly, the context just doesn't matter.
Taylor Loren posted
posted this. She the context doesn't matter. Well, that's wrong.
Hold on. That's totally wrong because if there if there's any
way you can defend Ethan, either Ethan's like a monster or she's
like just imitating him and showing like this is why this is
a critique, right? You give the same language back to show the
critique. Hey, it's really up to do it. Hey, it's really up to
do this.
She started it this time. What do you mean she started it? I
don't even know what you mean she started it. I'm saying for
this tweet, what Hutch is doing, this response is very clearly
to something Ethan said. And in that context, it is not absurd.
It's not crazy. It's not treating him like he's not human any
more than he was treating her like she's not human. >> She
was she was mock like mocking an Ethan post. I guess Ethan on
IG was posting about saying something like you should never cough
near Taylor Loren, which to be fair can be read in a few different
ways. But even if you read it in the worst way,
wait, what are the other ways you could
What? Wait, wait, what? I will just be your pay pig. >> Hold
on. >> We ban Ruben donated $3. Why did Top Bronson make
you look like Kenny Rogers? >> I have no idea.
I have no idea.
Whole thing started on Ethan's side because his employees said
they saw her at an event and she then said they were stalking
her. Weird.
Honestly, weird. Going to be honest. It's slimy for him to crop,
so it won't defend Hutch. He should have included it, but I don't
think they're the same. Ethan is mocking her as mentally ill
longco delusions where there's likely 0% chance she gets coughed
on. Wait, you understand that she is saying she is just giving
him back the same thing he did to her, right? Like like I understand
people will say she is melodramatic. She doesn't she's not sick,
but I don't know,
right? And I I would say I would say Ethan, you know, also might
be experiencing some delusions. Okay.
Now, I have no doubt the CPS call is real, but I'm saying in
terms of how much people are like talking him, how much he's
really getting harassed. I I think he's starting to get a little
delusional. Okay. Did she say it's long CO or something else?
Well, I think she has said she has long CO, but I thought in
general it's just that she's
right? And so, she thinks it's like bad.
And so, she's saying, "Look, here's the thing that's very upsetting
to you." I honestly, she might just be um what's the word?
uh agorophobic or whatever germaphobic is. I think there's a
word for germaphobia, right? That's not germaphobic, but if that's
what it is, she's like germaphobic.
So, like you're literally saying the thing that is is irrationally
going to upset her, right? And so, she goes, "Well, here look,
I don't care about you either." with the thing that he's been
complaining about online is the most the thing that upsets him
the most in the whole world. Like, that's where it went. She
he went to the thing where it's like, okay, she's explained how
how insanely like upset this makes her, right? She's explained
how this is ir well, not irrational, but if he believes it's
irrational, either it's real and it's [__] up or
it's irrational and it's still up, right? And then she just does
the same thing back. I think she she just gives the same energy
back, man. And if you leave out the context, people can't even
decide for their for themselves. It's obvious that it looks like
Taylor is crazy. She's evil. It doesn't even come close to joking
about CPS.
Like the CPS is antisocial. It's sociopathic,
dude. Oh, actually, um,
dude, the god, what's the I can't think of a CPS related name,
okay? But the Skullost needs to be
the mythology surrounding the Skullost needs to be debunked.
Okay. Nothing could be worse than joking about CPS is like
a wild I'm sorry you guys keep doing this. You keep saying CPS
as if that's an excuse for all of Ethan's behavior. It is not.
It's not. You can't just You can't just bomb civilians and then
go, "Well,
you have a right to exist. Did you know the Holocaust happened?
You can't do it. You can't do it. It's not okay. It's not okay.
It's not okay. All right. You cannot do
So the I we have to Can Norm Finkelestein get on it? We need
Norm Finkelstein to write the Skolocaust industry. Okay.
It needs to be written. The book is required reading at this
point.
Learn here about how we've used this terrible tragedy. This this
thing that did happen, right? This thing that did happen that
was bad
and is just as bad as it sounds in history. But we have we need
to learn how it's being weaponized against us. Okay? We need
to learn rapidly and deal with it. No, no, no, no, no. Hold on.
She's a diesor. I'm joking about it in the uh in the what's his
name? Norfinklestein way, right? Where he talks about the holoca
the idea of the Holocaust industry is that they use the Holocaust
to basically like do propaganda. But it is a tragedy. It's just
like you can't use that to give outweigh like you know costic
and toxic empathy to people who don't deserve it,
Like when they show you they don't deserve it, they can't just
say, "Well, the Holocaust happened," and then suddenly they're
allowed to do something. That can't be the way it works, even
in a roundabout way. So yeah, nobody's nobody here is saying
the Holocaust didn't happen or that it wasn't a tragedy. It was
just like I believe CPS, the Skulls, I believe those happened,
and we're sad. But I'm sorry you you can't you don't get to do
whatever you want now because of that.
You've used up all We gave Ethan an EBT card of goodwill, okay?
And he's kept he keeps swiping it. Skulls. Skull, skull, skull,
skull, CPS, skull, skull, skull, sword, CPS, skull, CPS, CPS,
CPS. And he is all out of credit. Okay,
there's no more goodwill left. He's all out of credit. It's over.
I don't care anymore. Talk about something else. It's just insane.
Um, you don't have to like
Ethan Klein to recognize that
calling CPS
because you don't like something a creator said is psychotic.
It's It's like actually psychotic.
You don't have >> Yes, it is psychotic.
It's also psychotic to hint at coughing on somebody who's imunocmpromised.
No, I'm sorry. Both both sides are
right? Both sides are psychotic. >> Have to like Ethan
to recognize this. I'm trying to find the original post now.
Hold on, >> dude. Sorry, I missed this Twitch chatter.
But Hutch, you can interpret it in a number of ways. I choose
to interpret this as Taylor Loren just doesn't want to just doesn't
want people to call CPS. That's all that's all she's saying.
Why are we acting like something crazy is going on?
Guys, guys, why are we acting like something crazy is going on
here?
They're just saying don't call She's just saying don't call CPS.
Totally. Honestly,
have we considered that this pag is lying about being imuninompromised?
Well, that's what I said. But then if she's lying about it and
it's like an irrational fear, right? Cuz she clearly takes precautions
that are totally inconveniencing her all the time. If it's just
an irrational fear, then you're like actually just tapping into
something that makes her primordially like fearful and scared
intentionally to [__] with her. Like that doesn't
make it better. And when you
when I read the the thing that um so she was mocking this post
from Ethan who said do not cough near Taylor Loren if you see
her. I cannot emphasize this enough under Hill. >> So he
read the context and still cut out the context. Well that's not
good. Actually when I was reading the context for this before
deciding it wasn't important actually when I was like deciding
it with full
with my full faculties coming to bear. Okay. and I chose to cut
that context out. Here's what I thought. >> Circumstances.
Should you ever cough near Taylor Lauren, if you see her in a
theater, leave. If you spot her on the subway, pull the emergency
cord. Do not risk it. You may not know it, but just by reading
this, you are currently stalking her, which is a crime. You will
go to jail. I cannot afford to lose any more viewers. So, stop
thinking about her right now. And most importantly, never, and
I mean never, cough anywhere near Taylor Loren's.
You can read that a couple different ways. Marty Epstein just
tipped 25exually.
Now I'm drunk. Can't connect to Citrix
Marty Epstein here is so bad. My boss gave me a promotion today.
We had a corporate holiday party. Now I'm drunk and can't connect
to Citrix VPN. Well, thanks Marty. Appreciate the 25. I think
that's going to get us uh we're just about we're maybe like one
sub away from two more hours on the stream. So, let's just go
ahead and right now we'll throw that six up there. Okay, we'll
throw those 6 hours up on the stream. We'll say we'll do six
hours from here on. Okay, thank you very much, Marty Epste. Appreciate
it, buddy. Love you. Happy holidays. Glad you got a promotion.
Everything's looking up for you. You can inform me on exactly
how economically like doomer pled I should be. We love Marty
Epstein here, guys. Okay, I love it.
I think I'm I think I'm five off or something with the 25
and three. Yeah, we're like five, eight off. No, seven off. >> I
mind when I read it. I could be wrong. >> Here, let me
back this up just a second. >> Or to lose any more viewers,
so stop thinking about her right now. And most importantly, never,
and I mean never cough anywhere near Taylor Loren.
>> You can read that a couple different ways. In my mind,
when I read it, I could be wrong. In my mind, when I read that,
it just seemed like he was mocking her. Um,
oh, >> Sophia, thank you very much for the five gifties
as well. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Let's go. Let's go. >> General,
she's It's a whole thing with her. It's a whole thing. She's
like, "Hey, is this guy arguing that my my unhinged meme that
plays on play pays uh sorry that plays on the other person's
like clear and obvious fear
is okay, but yours isn't? Is that that's what we're saying here?"
Huh. Very interesting. Very interesting argument. Um actually,
when when my guy does it, it's fine. When your guy does it, it's
not fine. That's actually how it works. I don't know if you know
that, but that's how that works. >> We're how many years
removed from the vaccine?
Five years removed from the vaccine and she's still living like
it's
And when I read that, I just felt like he was mocking her. He
wasn't trying to do like stochastic coughing. >> Okay.
Okay. Listen, I think that's what Taylor Loren is doing, too.
No. Wait. Does anybody here really think
>> Hold on. >> JSTLK, I'm sorry to reveal the truth.
I am the one who has always done the Bubba Ray McCoy, Rabbi Moshi
Lieovitz, Lil Teriff, and other characters.
>> Oh, that's awesome. I didn't know who it was for sure,
Marty Epstein. But I do appreciate the 25. And I do love Rabbi
Moshe Libo.
I love Bubba Ray McCoy.
I love
Rajesh. Okay, Raj is my favorite. So, thank you. A little tariff.
Yeah, a little. We love all these guys. Okay, so thank you very
much. Appreciate it, dude. Thank you very much for the 25. Very
generous. Massive holiday stream right now, guys. Let's go. >> Yeah,
he could have been. That could have been his meaning, but >> Ooh.
Top Bronson asks, "Were you Jizaw, Marty?" Were you Jizaw as
well? You think Ethan is honestly inciting bow warfare and Taylor
or do you think Taylor is joking? Wait, I think they're both
joking. I think they're clearly both joking. Like, they're both
joking in a way they know irritates the other person, but one
of them is doing it in response to the other person going there.
Yeah, I think it that's what it seems like. Unless Taylor Loren
before this was saying like, oh, was she doing something to to
cuz it seems like Ethan went to the thing that nailed at her
and she went to the thing that n him.
Well, it's not this post. I'm circling it, but it's not this
post. And I'm saying that obviously leaving that out that context,
right,
is crazy. Yeah, I think probably if you're asking me for my read,
I don't think Ethan wants Taylor coughed on. I don't think Taylor
wants CPS called. I think they're both just like poking at each
other. But if you leave one side of the joke of of like this
like uh whatever you're gonna call it, um poking at each other
out, you make it look like she's just like disingenuous. She's
just calling for CPS to be called. Like that's how it looks in
a vacuum, right? That she's just bringing up CPS for no reason.
And this is the worst kind of nick obviously.
Yes. Mutually assured Nick. So yeah, I just to me I don't think
either of them are serious.
I think but I think both of them are open to somebody from those
audiences or somebody around those people doing the thing. Yeah,
you could easily argue this. I don't think Ethan even is pro
clutching. I think Hutch is pro clutching for Ethan. He's like
guning.
That's that's what we're calling out here is Hutch Gunguarding
and being totally disingenuous about it. Like just lying about
it like this. This is a lie. when you intentionally cut that
context out, you're just lying.
Cuz he's saying, "Oh, look,
the post itself is saying, hey, look, she's like clearly just
calling for this, right?" He talks about, "Oh, it's dehumanizing."
What is incredible about her corner of the internet is they're
1,000% convinced that they're the good guys fighting evildoers
for a righteous cause. In their minds, there's nothing out of
bounds when they attack their enemies because their enemies are
onlogically evil. She He's He's literally accusing her of of
encouraging CPS calls here, right? and he's lying to do it. If
he really believed
if he really believed that he was in the right here and that
he could just do this directly, then why didn't he include the
context? Yeah, I know. I know she's a Dora. That took me a while
as well. It took her like having a debate with Destiny where
she completely dogwalked him for me to go, "Oh, maybe I don't
hate Taylor Ren anymore." You remember that? She just like totally
and completely and utterly dogwalked this guy. And I'm like,
"Oh, damn. Well, okay. I guess I can like you now. I guess I
don't have to treat you like a total now. Thank you. Thank you,
Taylor. Okay,
so apparently part one of two the joke and then somebody sent
me the other part. Part two of two, the
So apparently she said
this is somebody who like found her at some thing. She thinks
this person was stalking her. So it looks like So when he made
the joke originally, it does look like she might have doxed somebody
who was seeing her at some event. Is that I that's the best I
can tell. Is this is this what happened, guys? Did she Did she
dox one of Ethan Klein's employees saying like this is a crazy
person? Blank a healthcare company, but she spends her days abusing
disabled people and calling for disabled people to be including
a high-profile journalist. I hope disabled people realize that
companies like Blank help facilitate or what they help facilitate.
What is this for? Yeah, I don't know what this is.
I could go look it up, but I'm not I don't want to broadcast
the docks either. It's an H3 fan stalking her. Well, is it though?
Well, is it though? You'd have to So, people are saying people
are saying it's an H3 fan stalking her IRL. But is it? Or is
this
in a way that you have to be totally
completely sidescing
stalking? Oh, I'm I'm already watching it, Kilo. Thank you. we'll
watch the rest of the Hutch stuff here and then I will go we
can look into this. Okay, we'll try to look into the T thing,
see what's going on there. >> And then she responded to
that by saying, "I hope no one ever calls CPS on Ethan Klein
again." Like the whole that whole thing was such a significant
escalation. The CPS stuff was such a significant escalation.
And I don't think that this corner of the internet, her pocket
of the internet, the sort of Hassan orbit, I don't think they
I I don't think they get that.
I really don't think they understand
>> Do they not? Wow. >> Stuff was such a significant
escalation.
>> And I don't think that this corner of the internet,
her pocket of the internet, the sort of Hassan Orbit, I don't
think they I I don't think they get that.
I really don't think they understand that. Or they
Yeah, I he he just blames it. This is what I said. Like I understand
why Hassan won't apologize for he's done because literally his
only downside all of the people criticizing him it's like even
when he goes guys do not call like it's actually totally insane
Ethan's a good father right even when he stands up and says that's
crazy never do that it doesn't matter Hutch is still going to
blame Hassan for it he can say it totally clearly totally obviously
for everybody to hear stand on business stand up against anyone
who says it's okay which by the way not that many people I think
most of his audience agreed with him Oh yeah, that is totally
deranged. Don't call CPS on this guy. Right. But he can stand
up business and say, "Yeah, no, it's really bad. Don't do that."
But then Hutch just says, "Oh, well, it's all the Hassan Orbit."
At this point, Tog has grounds to sue. Um,
who? Wait, who would she have grounds to sue? I have no idea.
I do have to look more into the stalking stuff. I didn't have
time to do that today. I was honestly mostly collecting the Candace
Owens. Do and they think it was justif. Is this on like a raid
boss to every Midwit streamer? A hutch, Connor, Aerodite, probably
more. I don't think this is uh such a huge shot at me. You actually
for making this making this point. Um I used to make a bunch
of money, okay? It's it's free money. It's just free money. But
I was at least fair about it. I didn't just lie. Like I I feel
like you could be fair and go after the guy, but if you're just
going to lie about it, like it's not as bad. Maybe that's the
thing is people are finding that there's a demand for Han hate
and he can't keep up with the supply of like I don't know criticizable
actions so people have to go and start criticizing him for things
he has nothing to do with. I didn't cover that Wendy now. Yeah,
I don't think you could sue for harassment. Hutch this was blatantly
malicious. Oh no, I don't think so. I don't think so. I I don't
think so because Hutch didn't say I'm misrepresent. He said it
doesn't matter. Like he's he's not putting actual malice on the
record. He's putting actual on the record, right? I don't know
how you get him for actual malice when he's just putting actual
he's putting his actual IQ on the record and the judge is going
to find him like not fit to stand trial. All right. It's not
it's not going to be a thing. Can't be a thing.
>> What? Because they feel like he is evil. They think
they think he's him and Ela. They think Ethan and Ela are literally
evil. And so there's nothing you can do. I wonder what you would
say about the person who took a thing like this that was reciprocal,
cut the context, tried to make the other person look evil while
commenting on how the sides makes everybody evil to each other.
Actually, no, their sides makes them all evil to Ethan but not
vice versa. Like there's just no introspection there. There's
nothing going on. There's no sparks going off in his brain.
There's nothing happening, man. There's nothing happening up
there. It's all empty. There's so much space up in this bald
dome right now. Okay, there's just infinite space up there.
It's actually a pocket dimension. Okay, you go you go in there.
It is the entirety of Buckingham Palace. Okay, all the space
in the world. All the the sprawling grounds in the middle of
London. It's crazy. Just all up in this brain, all up in this
noggin, okay?
Except all of the paintings instead of the queen, they're of
Ethan Klein or Ela Klein. Okay. >> Marty just tipped $20.
>> I just connected to the Citrix VPN after authenticating
my credentials success. Here is something to celebrate this
>> Let's go, Marty. We appreciate it. Thank you very much,
Marty. I appreciate it, buddy. Thank you so much. Love you. Love
the donos. Super appreciate it, dude. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Congratulations on connecting to your >> Do to them
that would be out of bounds.
You can just say whatever. You can joke about the CPS stuff.
You can kind of encourage it. If Ethan Klein said you went bald
by nature and not by choice, would you call him a liar? Pisco
must know. I think that would be a misunderstanding. I'm sure
all those people who think Pisco is wrong will go and argue with
him. Right.
Right. I'm sure all of those people who want to take little jabs
at Pisco will go get on a stream and not run like little. Yeah.
I'm posit I'm sure this will happen. I'm positive that all these
people will hop on and have no problems. He takes Collins after
all. Oh, he does take Collins. Yes. Now, it's very interesting
the I Dude, unfortunately, this whole space I think
there's a there's a current thing right now. It's basically are
people going to swallow this like doxing lie? There's there's
a bunch of people who used to watch me and Queman very aware
of our streams and they're very aware that like this doxing lie
>> has been perpetuated right donated $3 unlike Marty Epstein
I don't have a VPN but I did sit on my nuts for the first time
this year >> that's rough dude getting up there getting
up there Reben Rubin appreciate the three okay next thing you
know Reuben Rubin's going to donate $50 and say actually I was
Marty Epstein the whole time very
Okay.
So,
where were we here? Oh, right. So, basically there's like there's
a part of this community it's I think there there happens to
be like five to 10 people who aren't really willing to just go
along with like the lies
and hopefully Pisco is one of them. You would hope, right?
Because again, I was just I was trying to like tally stuff up
today on the doxing front and it's like, oh, there's like only
really one party that is like verifi sorry, two parties in this
entirety of like Destiny's past four years that are responsible
for h maybe three parties that are responsible for 95% of the
doces, right? Like you can actually attribute it to like
and Destiny's one of those three people. I'm not one. Queen's
not one. Our communities aren't one. It's it's crazy. When KF
said they watch Jtock in the same post, they call him an Fsler.
That makes him a doxer. Oh, I've seen some people make that argument.
I don't know.
I don't I don't care if KF likes the stream or not. It doesn't
matter to me. I'm going to cover the content the way I'm going
to cover the content. Ultimately, trying to cater your content
to KF would be stupid. Trying to totally cut anything that could
be related to KF or talk about KF or something that would also
be stupid, right? I'm just going to give my opinion the way it's
naturally going to form and that's how it is. Okay. Sorry. We
do need to get back to this content though. The >> Ethan
Klein said you win. >> Oh yeah. I think there's just a
couple people like Doobie is one. Doobie is one who's just like
probably never going to swallow any of the lies. He'll he'll
just go like, "Do you have proof of anything you're saying? Otherwise,
you're a like Doobie. There's Lactoid. I'm trying to think of
who else." And these guys like have been in this space long enough
that thankfully, you know, it'll never, you know, it'll never
go down quite that easy. I hope Pix uh I hope Pisco would be
one of those people. Really? Uh Rei would ask for proof, right?
I think so. But I I don't know how often Re goes on those streams.
Really is doing good in terms of his content. It seems like he's
getting lots of views, but I don't know if he goes on I don't
know if he does the debate panels. I just haven't seen them.
But yeah, we'll see.
We will see. Okay, we continue. We continue. >> And baldled
by nature and not by choice, would you call him a liar? Pisco
must know. I think that would be a misunderstanding. I would
correct him. Obviously, it is a choice, not something that was
imposed upon me by father of time. You intentionally cropped
the post I'm cutting of Ethan Klein saying these exact words,
but about killing me. >> This is why you shouldn't be soy
because now Hutch to his audience. I mean, realistically, unfortunately,
Hutch could just go Hutch doesn't have to say anything for this
audience, right?
He could just do a tone indicator. He doesn't even have to. He's
doing so much work that doesn't need to be done. There's so much
effort here that's just wasted on these people. All you could
do is go, "Oh, really, Taylor? Really? That's what you think?"
And then you could move on and they'd all go, "Yes, Hutch. Brilliant
response." Yes. Brilliant, sir. I love how you I love how you
really dissected that idea. That was fantastic. Thank you, Mr.
Hutch. Thank you.
Right. He just has to show Yeah, he has been doing TikTok debates.
He just has to show that Taylor's wrong. He's with his attitude,
with his tone, and that's all it requires. But so I I'm going
to criticize Taylor, though. You seem really soy when you say
it's about killing you when it's about coughing on you. I understand
you're immuno compromised. I do get it and I believe that. And
I believe you feel like this is him talking about hurting you
like tangibly. Okay. Uh I don't know if you covered this already,
but this wasn't the joke Taylor was responding to. Literally
someone asking for someone to cough on Taylor to put us out of
our misery. I did cover that. So I'm I'm saying yes. I'm very
aware that Ethan Klein understands the joke, understands how
Taylor sees it, and so at minimum he understands that she lives
in fear of germs and of, you know, being imuno compromised and
being susceptible to just dying from little random microbes that
nobody can see. And so, realistically, that's how I look at this
is Ethan took the thing that she's talked about online that she's
incredibly like concerned about, scared of, and then she just
did the same thing back. She just flipped it and was like, "Yeah,
there you go. That's how I see this. I don't think either one
of them wants the other person really harmed
But again, I don't know. I don't know what Hutch is going to
say. I feel like he's just going to focus on the me thing and
go, "Really? Coughing on you is going to you really?
Really?" Can we take serious who anyone serious who claims they
have long co? Uh yeah, absolutely. Do you know who uh do you
know who Jonathan Taves is?
Former captain of the Chicago Blackhawks hockey dynasty of the
2010s.
He got long co. He had to stop playing in the NHL for years.
He made a comeback. I don't think his comeback went very well,
but he was like out of commission for years. I there there are
absolutely cases of long co that totally people.
Yeah. 100%. >> I I just can't believe these are like >> Okay,
hold on. She's a dies.
I I think we're focusing way too much on the wrong thing, right?
I think that Ethan Klein was knowingly
joking about something that Taylor is scared is going to kill
her,
right? He's he's invoking that fear and and the idea that somebody
could just go do that, right? He's invoking that very intentionally
and Taylor Loren responds in kind. So, I understand that you're
like, "Oh, one is a tangible thing." In terms of trying to dehumanize
the other person and doing whatever you can to with them, what
is the difference?
because it seems pretty obvious that that's what Ethan Klein
is trying to do, right? I think we've we've all agreed that probably
neither one of them actually wants it to happen to the other
person and Taylor Loren is just responding back with the same
energy. So, I don't I don't know. I really don't know where we're
going with this.
Pretty irrational fear though. No, not if she's truly immuno
compromised. And again, she does all of the work, right? She
does all of the work. So, I believe the fear is real. Even if
it is irrational, even if it's like uh the fear is real, even
if maybe the underlying disease isn't. And I don't know. That's
just me saying I can give you that it might be fake. I have no
[__] idea and I don't think we will ever know, right?
But she clearly puts a ton of work into it. Yeah, her behavior
does line up with being imunocmpromised. Absolutely it does.
And that's I to me that's what you have to take into account
here. Absolutely you do. that if you just ignore that that her
behavior is like all commensurate with somebody who's imunocmpromised,
somebody's really like
then like she's not she's not just faking it. She's not just
saying it to get like virtue points from anyone. She does a bunch
of extra work. She wears masks to all of her interviews and it
looks so stupid. Why would she do that? Yeah. Okay. Anyway, we
continue. >> There's something about Taylor Loren to me
that's just like it feels like a rested development. You know
what I mean? Like, >> so this ultimately I'm
I never really
bought the what do you call it? I never really bought the misogyny
like coke from people, but like at some point it really is just
this is wretched. I hate her. Anything that happens to her is
fine. Like that's basically the baseline for Hutch and Hutch
viewers with regards to the Caseyron thing, with regards to Taylor.
That's what it comes down to. They will never be able to like
tangibly defend their positions. they'll never be able to actually
defend anything they say. So like realistically when you are
totally irrational about the things you say and the things you
advocate for, I just assume there's something else underlying
it, right? Yeah. So there it is. I Taylor's totally arrested
development. Yeah. Okay. Any criticism he applies to Taylor Ren
applies equally to Ethan Klein. Obviously. Okay. Obviously. It
feels like um like she's Oh, I will say maybe not misogyny with
Hutch, but just total irrational hatred for these people. Like
it's just it's just hatred.
That's the only explanation because I guarantee you if you showed
this to Hutch and you said you understand that by cutting that
context you are doing the same thing back to her that you were
complaining about, right? And what Hutch would see is like a
photograph of oh [__] a photograph of Bey from Hunger
Games and oh and Hannibal Lectar.
[__] They see the Westworld photo. Okay. Looks like
nothing to me. Hold on. I I [__] it up. so badly.
Anthony Hopkins, that's who I was going to say. God damn it.
But he he basically wouldn't be able to see it. He like can't
see it. He can't even He can't even understand that he's doing
the same thing, right? I meant to do the Westworld meme. You
show him like this picture and get him to talk about it and he
go like, "Oh, that's like a super base tweet." Wait, you cut
the context, though. Yeah. Yeah. It doesn't matter. Why doesn't
it matter? Um, well, cuz she's fake.
What proof do you have of that? Uh she's like a and like totally
she's like totally like the biggest victim in all of the internet.
Okay. Why do you think that? Um well uh I've covered a lot of
stuff and she's like a total [__]
Okay. I don't like it's not based on the current situation. It's
just based on I don't like this stupid rancid
every time. And all I'm asking is try to evaluate the situation
as if you didn't think she was a totally rancid.
That's all. That's that's it. Just try to evaluate it as if you
didn't feel this in your bones a thousand% right.
This is exactly what you feel in your bones.
>> Oh, sorry. But about her, like you're like, "Oh, she
is evil. I can do whatever I want. I can say whatever I want
about her." >> There's obviously a part of her that is
>> Mind readader.
I'm asking you, what is his basis for this? It's past behavior,
right? She's He's just looking at past behavior and going, "She's
lying. This is like so silly. Oh my god, this is so silly." Right?
So, I'm telling you, to me, if you if you consistently take positions
that you can't back up at all, that you get consistently embarrassed
on, there's something else underlying those positions, and you
aren't really even arguing that you're correct. You're ar you're
basically just arguing for other people to feel your emotions.
>> Grown up enough to get a journalism degree and have
a career, and you know, that does take
something, right? like you need to be a grown-up to do that,
but there's this other part of her that just feels so stunted.
Um, you can almost imagine like this is somebody that you knew
in high school, you know what I mean? That everybody was irritated
with all the time. And I just Yeah, I Yeah, I just I I wish I
knew more about her origin
>> She's just so annoying. She's just so annoying, guys.
>> I wish I knew more about her heel turn about like what
made her this way. Um, of course, no one would get outraged if
you included that key context. So, you have to deceptively crop
my post to remove the context. Oh, he is he is he not going to
Dude, he did this to Straight Raid, too. Straight raid like totally
owned him. I remember their debate. She like totally owns him
on a point and he just like moves on and pretends it didn't happen.
Bro, what? Taylor brought doxing mainstream. Maybe I think like
you maybe you can argue that there's a journalistic interest
in the what do you call it like a a public interest right in
her doxing libs of Tik Tok. You could maybe argue that. I don't
think so. I think it was doxing but I think it was like bad.
Yeah. Personally, but you I think people do argue there's a journalistic
interest there. He knows he's just intentionally misleading people
about the context of my post in order to whip up more hate and
harassment toward me. Nobody embodies
the archetype of the crybully like her.
>> Ethan Klein. Oh, Ethan Klein so much more. Ethan Klein
so much more.
Dude,
so that it's crazy that I watched the first like 90 seconds of
this and I said at the beginning of the segment, watch for Hutch's
criticisms of Taylor Loren's and then try to figure out which
one doesn't apply the same way like equally back on Ethan Klein.
You think Hutch wouldn't make this point in a serious debate?
Well, he wanted to talk to Bisco about the whole H3 thing. And
he basically had to
forget how to evaluate conditional hypotheticals like one of
the 60 IQ people in the copy pasta. Like it was actually a what
did you how would you feel this morning if you didn't have breakfast
moment? And they all pointed it out and laughed at him. And he
never ever ever responded. He never ever
just dealt with it and and and
addressed the hypothetical. He just
So, I've watched him make incredibly stupid points in debates.
So, I have no idea why you would think in a serious debate he
wouldn't make this point. Can you show me a serious debate Hutch
has had with somebody where he doesn't make points? Is that a
thing that's ever happened? Non non-viewer non-viewer callin
cuz I remember I've watched his I watched his chorus media one
where he did that debate panel with Dickers and some other people
on it. He was totally
I watched that debate last night with Pisco. He was totally I
don't know. I I would love to see a debate where Hutch does really
well.
Oh yeah, Fabian Liberty. True. I remember that now. Was going
to say his AI debate today, but you me on the call-in point.
Yeah, I'm I'm saying like probably with viewers he probably does
okay,
but I'm just saying has he ever debated with somebody and not
just been totally like embarrassed?
She is the crybully of the internet. It's just the perfect example
of a crybully. You know what it is though? I'm just salty that
I never got invited to the 9/11 parties. That's >> what
What is he talking about? >> That's what it is. I'll admit
to it. I'm being petty.
It just bothers me knowing that Taylor Loren gets invited to
all these really sick and fun 911 parties.
So, he's not going to at all
respond to the questions she asked, the point she made. He's
just going to go, "Remember how Taylor Loren is bad? Actually,
remember how Taylor Loren is actually bad?" Guys, I know that
she just called me out for something and I could respond to it,
but instead, I would like to remind you that Taylor Loren is
bad. Taylor Loren is very bad.
So cool. What What a massive dub. What a What a massive dub.
Is Is that some meme? I don't I don't know about Well, I assume
it's like something to do with the anti-semitic side she's on
or something,
but I'm I'm just pointing out that he clearly sidestepped the
criticism. Hey, you cut out crucial context to this. That makes
it make way more sense, but I'm less hatable, so you cropped
it. And instead of responding, he actually blanks out is the
golem programming resets. He forgets what he was reading and
he goes on to the next comment. Okay. many such cases and I've
not I've not gotten a single invite to a 911 party and I'm like
what the
don't I look like a guy who would enjoy a 9/11 party? She's right
about that. I'm petty about that. I'm petty. I want to be invited
to these things. I don't get invited to them.
She's hanging
at Kilotonics. Just going to say you're on thin ice. I I think
Kilo shared the thing he was talking about here, but I I don't
have it. Hold on. Give me a second. [__] Where is
it? Kilo, send me that screenshot if you're watch. You are watching.
Send me the send me the thing the comment you made cuz it was
like totally innocuous. Oh, wait. Maybe it's here though. Oh,
here it is. Never mind. I I thought you got removed from the
chat or something. So, my bad. It might be silly to suggest she
die or something, but Ethan is literally implicitly directing
people to harass her. How can you just ignore that? Well, oh
man, I don't think he seriously wants people to harass her, but
I'd say the risk of those things happening is, you know, maybe
there's a higher chance of the CPS thing, but the CPS thing requires
work to put in. The coughing also requires work to put in. Yeah,
I don't really think either one's going to happen. I don't think
either one really advocates for it, to be honest. >> You
want me to link her 9/11 party tweets? Uh, you could, but I'm
not even I'm not saying they didn't happen. Other people are
saying they didn't happen. So if you want to fight with some
chatter who said they didn't happen, I'm just saying that it's
not related to what is happening here. That he is clearly instead
of responding,
he is just bringing up something else that was bad
so that he doesn't have to respond and he get he can get his
audience's attention on something else. That's the only goal,
right?
Zero attempt to engage at all. >> That I'm petty about
that. I'm petty. I want to be invited to these things. I don't
get invited to them.
She's hanging out with all the zoomers and being super cool and
probably
riding skateboards and
playing with fidget spinners and whatever whatever else zoomers
do. And I'm over here like, "What the [__] Where's
my 911 party invite?" That is hysterical though,
dude. His is one super mod. Implicitly how how could you argue
that? I mean, if he's not implicitly doing it, then Taylor isn't
saying anything. Then Taylor is literally just arguing.
Does Does that mod not understand that if Ethan isn't calling
for anything to happen that that Taylor isn't either? How do
you How do you make it Taylor is clearly making trying to make
it happen, but Ethan isn't
very confusing. The framing here,
you intentionally cropped the post. I'm cutting of Ethan Klein
saying these exact words, but about me.
She typed that sentence out and then she hit send. She just put
that on the internet. That's cringe. Could we not focus? So I
listen, I understand you're a streamer. You got to focus on the
really up thing she said that like the thing you can just point
out is soy and goofy as but couldn't you like actually critically
engage just a little bit? Just a little. Just a tiny bit. Um
Impossible. I don't really think um hold on. I don't really think
Hutch is misogynistic in the same way. I it is something I get
from the audiences and I do say like oh this is just some wretched
and that's how he thinks about it. I do think that's how he thinks
about it. I don't think he's broadly misogynistic. I think there
is a lot of misogyny underlying it cuz it seems like the least
forgivable people tend to be women, right? The person I'm going
to hold everything against forever is usually women. But I don't
I don't really I don't really think or at least I haven't seen
a reason to believe he's misogynistic to be honest. Um, when
you get audience captured though, you do tend to pick up some
of their opinions that are based on some things you wouldn't
like without knowing the source of them, right? So, his audience's
hatred for Taylor Loren that he's picked up and the love for
Ethan Klein. I don't know if you know the reasons behind those.
So, while not anti So, well, not
I do think probably a lot of the hatred from Taylor Loren or
for Taylor Loren comes from a misogynistic place. Although, it's
not to excuse all of her actions because I know she's done really
on the internet, too. Okay. just I understand I trust me I very
much dislike Taylor Loren's before any of this stuff happened.
I think she's kind of doing better now. I do think she overstates
some things. I do think she like misrepresents some things. She's
not perfect. She's not like great but she's not the worst. Okay,
there are worse than her now.
This is and and that's an improvement. Okay, that's an improvement
from where she was. She was like she was actually really really
really before like unironically really
>> She just put that on the internet. This is what Ethan
is making fun of. By the way,
I don't think he I don't think he is like trying to do stochastic
coughing terrorism. I don't think that was his intention. I think
he's just mocking her.
Okay, that >> Can we Can we be real that
probably if we want to talk about things that aren't going to
cause problem, can we just be real about this? I'm going to say
something that for the skullost people is basically a second
skull. Okay, but I'm going to go ahead and say it. I'm going
to say the craziest thing right now. And I'm going to say that
probably if there was a CPS call that was totally disconnected
from reality and they went there and they talked to his kids
and it was like completely made up and he goes, "Hey, is people
on the line harassing me?" That if you call and you give a totally
unbelievable call again is no risk. I think in terms of getting
a CPS call a second time, Ethan Klein's at essentially zero risk.
Now, I obviously don't advocate for it. I don't think you should
do it. But I think in terms of him pretending that somebody saying,
"Oh, the CPS call was fine." is actually putting him or his family
at risk. I think he's totally
okay. Now, I understand that that's like an a high crime. It's
it's like a high crime to do that with regards to the Skullost
or the CPS call or the sword or whatever. Okay? But that's what
it is. Okay?
That is just that's just the truth. Take it or leave it. Nazani
with $5. Taylor claims to be immuno compromised, so she's claiming
Ethan's post is a call to harm or even kill her, but Taylor has
credibility issues. No, I understand the context. It's It's [__]
ridicul. Uh, the police department does not always ignore the
SWAT thing. They do evaluate when they have influencers. They
do evaluate whether or not it's believable. They do evaluate
with other signals, right? They'll have people they can call.
This is something they set up in a whole bunch of places. So,
I don't know. I don't know what you're saying. I'm not saying
always. mostly. What evidence do you have that it's mostly in
2025? I don't I don't think there's any evidence. By the way,
you don't call CPS. I think I think calling CPS is I I think
I gave this take at the time. It might be slightly worse than
swatting,
right? If Ethan's kids were
Oh, man. I think it's worse than swatting. Okay. Cuz I think
you there is a much higher average chance for doing some kind
of harm to that family, right? swatting it's like okay the downside
of swatting is like super bad but realistically it basically
never gets to the downside part the CPS call I say like the average
case there's an average case that your kids might remember that
that might do something that you might have to explain that to
other people like it it almost in the average case can cause
harm in your life right so I think I think the CPS call is worse
than swatting people
so I don't think you should do it but I don't think he's at very
much risk at this point though dev off with 21 months thank you
I don't know if she's immuno compromised. I don't I really have
no idea. Maybe she is, but I I think there's a a fair case to
make to be extremely skeptical of the >> Okay. Can Hutch
make that case? I hope somebody just asked, "Can you make that
case?" Cuz I would love to see someone make that case on the
fly. Like, so he's saying there's a really good chance that she's
just making this up based on what?
And again, I believe it would just go back to
Right. It would just go back to, well, actually, I just think
she's a total
She's just a totally wretched who's done evil things in the past.
It won't be based on evidence that she's faking it. It will just
be based on her other p on her past as somebody who's like very
dislikable, does very like annoying and gross things on the internet.
Just actually openly advocating for um
like always using somebody's past against them forever, never
letting them move past it. Kind of odd. You ever seen Taylor
Loren's debate with soy pill over the whole her whole uh the
over the her whole obsession with masks? It's trippy and where
she's coming from is a bit more understandable once you hear
her out. But I think she comes off as hysterical the most on
this. Well, she was hysterical to say about me. It is. But unfortunately,
I can just do the thing where I go, "Yeah, that's hysterical."
But about coughing on me when I feel I'm when I'm im imuninompromised.
Right. That's like what you if you just do that word swap coughing
on me when I'm immuno compromised risking my safety then it's
totally fine. What has she even done that's bad? There's the
doxing of libs of Tik Tok and there was like one or two other
things that I can't think of off the top of my head but I do
remember disliking her over like based solely on her statements
alone. I'm trying to think of what they are off the top of my
head. Oh, she she is like very dishonest. I've read a lot of
her reporting. When I've read some of her reporting, it is openly
dishonest. The Keell stuff was bad. The Keelles sweeping was
real real bad. Okay, it was kind of disastrous. The Keell sweeping
was like totally unforgivable. All right, and I say that obviously
not liking Destiny, but she was not on the right side of that.
I'm pretty confident I remember her like straight up lying in
some article, but maybe I have to throw back and and rethink
it or something. But
that's that's the one that to me I think Taylor Loren and Briana
Woo the careful stuff I was like oh yeah you guys forever you're
the worst. Was that her or Alyssa Marante? It was her.
It was her. I'm I'm positive it was her but anyway we'll we'll
keep watching. Give me a second. I need to use the bathroom.
Be right back. >> 21 months. Thank you. I don't know if
she's immuno compromised. I don't I really have no idea. Maybe
she is, but I I think there's a a fair case to make to be extremely
skeptical of the things that she says. Okay, hold on. Let's go.
Let's go to the next one here. Um, Jasmine Crockett recently
announced that she's going to run for Texas Senate. She showed
up on CNN. Let's hear her out.
Let's give her a chance.
Maybe she'll be a good candidate. I don't know. the best in the
upcoming March upcoming general election. March is the primary.
Crockett is jumping in right ex as Texas Democratic Congressman
Colin All Red is bowing out. Sources tell us that she asked him
to withdraw from the primary citing polling that shows her with
the best chance of winning. That makes Crack. >> Okay,
I'm back. All right.
I thought it was [__] up that he switched over right
now. Hold on. Brianna Woo is incomparable. Taylor means well.
Recante lacks intelligence to be evil. Oh, I don't think she's
comparable to Woo, actually. But I'm saying that's where I like
really decided I just couldn't stand those people with Woo. It
was the uh Yeah, it was the the Ke stuff.
I just couldn't stand those people. Who is Keeffles? Don't worry
about it, dude. It would be I think at some point we will actually
go back and read that whole Keffles manifesto at some point because
I was I was taking a look at it recently. It's just it's crazy
how accurate it was for the time and how accurate it remains
today. It's like it's really well done.
It's really really well done.